si como veis continúan las filas ante
los centros de votación que ya hace
varias horas que han abierto sus puertas
en estos comicios históricos en los que
se esperan que se batan todos los
récords de participación en las urnas se
espera que más de 150 millones de
personas vayan a votar para que os
hagáis una idea y como referencia en el
2016 votaron alrededor de 138 millones
de personas el candidato demócrata joe
biden ha comenzado este día de
elecciones haciendo una visita expresa
al cementerio aquí en delaware donde se
encuentran enterrados sus dos hijos y su
primera esposa poco después ha tomado un
avión y ha puesto rumbo a scranton su
ciudad natal esa ciudad que le vio nacer
hace ya 77 años en el estado de
pensilvania que se ha convertido ya en
la piedra angular de estas elecciones el
demócrata ha planteado su campaña desde
un principio como una crítica a la
gestión que donald trump ha hecho de
esta pandemia y se ha presentado como el
único que puede volver a unificar a un
país tomado por esta ola
estas raciales desde hace ya varios
meses